make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and we got to be a little quiet in this
video because Mirai is actually getting
some rest
so we don't want to wake her up but you
know I I I'm coming back here again with
with information from my source right
for those of you guys who saw my video
we were talking about Christian Bale and
the idea of like gore the god butcher
and we were talking about Black Adam and
different things like that
the idea was that that there were rumors
circulating around that Christian Bale
was gonna play some character in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and a lot of
people were pointing the finger at like
Gore the god butcher but Maya but I had
this source that kind of came to me and
was dropping all this information to me
on on like all these things that were
happening both in like the DC Cinematic
Universe and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe projects that were coming later
on down the road and and they've proven
to be accurate up to this point right
which is awesome and so as a result of
that you know they came to me again
right and they said hey man you know I
don't know if you're aware of everything
going on with regards to like these
rumors of Krasinski meeting with like
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and all
that kind of stuff and I said yeah I saw
these news articles coming out from all
these different companies and whatnot
that were saying that like the rumors
and and so on would that Krasinski was
meeting with the MCU and that he was
talking about various things that he was
going to do but like nobody seems to
know anything and and they said well
okay here's the thing
Krasinski meeting with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is not a rumor it's
true
Krasinski has has met and is meeting
with members of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now this is the part that's
kind of a little bit of hearsay and
rumor and it's kind of unsure Krasinski
meeting under two terms right the first
one is to play a character and the
second one is to potentially direct and
so if that's true that's actually pretty
big because for the first time we don't
really have anybody in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe who is starring in a
role and then like directing a film
right the closest we got to that was
John Favreau
he was happy Hogan right he wasn't
really the star of Iron Man he was kind
of like a co-star like two or three
times removed honestly I think he was
more of a co-star the Gwyneth Paltrow's
character was they were kind of even but
Robert Downey jr. was the star of the
Iron Man movies right you know Jon
Favreau is an incredible actor he's an
amazing director and the guy looks the
guy seems like he's really really cool
where the guy seems like he's awesome
hanging out with I would love to get a
beer with with Jon Favreau and just like
talk about random stuff didn't even have
to be about like Marvel movies just like
random things and it seems like it would
be an absolute blast but nonetheless
this would be pretty big and who
be pretty huge but in terms of the the
role that he's supposed to be playing
the rumors beyond this are that like
Krasinski's meeting to play Reed
Richards in the Fantastic Four and and
honestly myself and a lot of other
people have been saying this needs to be
a thing and have been saying this for a
long long time right like for awhile and
I know there are a lot of people out
there who disagree there are a lot of
people out there who say that's that's
not really the case and even then the
question kind of comes into play how do
you get Krasinski and how do you get
read into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in the first place and we'll talk about
that here in a minute but you know the
question is you know can he actually
play the character into the detractors
out there to the the people who don't
really believe that he can't bear with
me for a second because I think I can
convince you that he can right and I
think we've had this discussion before
but I don't mind retreading water
because it's a cool topic to talk about
with Krasinski when if we were talking
about him like immediately after the
office I would say you're right I would
say you're on your where you're a
hundred percent right that Krasinski is
not not I wouldn't say he's not equipped
I would say he hasn't demonstrated the
ability to show that he can play Reed
Richards now that's the nature of acting
right like you don't know a role a
person can play until they play that
role and then sometimes it works
sometimes it does right like nobody knew
Al Pacino could play the role of a
mobster until he played Michael Corleone
of The Godfather and then you could play
the role of a mobster right so like
sometimes you just got to give him a
break and just sort of see what happens
but with Krasinski and with the idea
Reed Richards it really kind of makes
things interesting right because what
we're talking about here is we're
talking about a character from Marvel
Comics that's basically pulling
double-duty right with Tony Stark it was
much the same way well you had to have a
guy who was super intelligent and then a
guy who could do action sequences when
it came to the Incredible Hulk was a
little bit different right because you
didn't really have Mark Ruffalo propert
running around and doing action
sequences you kind of did to a degree we
had CGI you know making up for that so
whatever he was physically unable to do
CGI could correct that but with regards
to Reed Richards it doesn't necessarily
work that way it does so far in terms of
his ability to stretch and different
things like that but you know you kind
of have to believe that like Reed can
pull those those kinds of things off you
know that Krasinski can pull those kinds
of things off right and so you know you
got to believe that he's a guy that can
play the action sequences if it comes
down to it right somebody invades the
backs you're building any kind of beat
six to his arm a little bit but not like
you know you know fifty feet away from
him or something on those lines but you
guys understand what I'm saying right so
if the long and short of this is that if
we were talking about Krasinski
immediately after the office you'd hear
no argument from me there
probably I wouldn't be as far as to say
he couldn't do it but I'd go as far as
to say he hasn't demonstrated that he
could and then after that we got like 13
hours we got a quiet place and we got
Jack Ryan specifically the last movie in
the last series are what demonstrated
his ability to play Reed Richards with a
quiet place this was a movie where
Krasinski talked twice right he'll that
was that was it there were only two
instances where he spoke the first
instances when he was under the
waterfall with his son and the second
instance is when he screamed at the end
of the movie and that was it right aside
from that he had to communicate over the
course of a two hour long film he had to
communicate what he was feeling what he
was thinking how scared he was how
excited he was how nervous he was you
know how concerned he was yeah he had to
convey all these emotions and all these
feelings through body language and he
had to do it in such a way to where it
resonated with us as the viewer and he
and Emily Blunt did it like that it was
it was amazing how well they pulled it
off and just by that by acting with body
language alone and with no speech is
exceedingly difficult to do right if at
any point in that movie you were looking
at it and you were saying like okay I
understand where he is right between the
context and his body language I get how
he's feeling him and what's going on
didn't like then he's done his job
perfectly
right and I feel like he nailed it in
that movie but really I think that the
most empowering aspect is the Jack Ryan
TV show if you never saw the Jack Ryan
TV show season 1 and season 2 are
amazing and I think season one's better
than season 2 but you know it's it's
absolutely amazing
but the Jack Ryan series is kind of you
know it's technically he's a CIA analyst
but for all intents and purposes he's an
action guy right and like he's running
and using engaging in firefights and all
that kind of stuff it's it's super
high-octane action and and it is great
because it's what you would expect for
somebody who would be able to play
someone like Reed when it comes to
presents key right like you look at him
being able to run and jump you know
being able to fight look at him being
able to like engage and shoot out stuff
and things like that that's more stuff
than Reed Richards would do right in
Marvel Comics you don't see Reed
Richards jumping into shootouts right
you don't see him pulling out like I go
out 19 and like firing off shots you
know like you don't see that happening
because of that he's able to pull off
action sequences that he's not going to
need for the Marvel Cinematic Universe
you know it's it's like doing extra
credit right like he's more than capable
of being able to pull off the role of
Reed in terms of being smart being able
to play the smart guy that's not hard to
do right like all you have to do is just
say things that sound
smart and then you look like the smart
guy right I mean that's what that's what
Robert Downey jr. did Robert Downey jr.
is by no means an unintelligent man but
there's nobody in the world this like a
Tony Stark s character whether
developing technology that advanced you
know like in MoMA comics you know Tony
Stark built a Dyson Sphere around the
Sun right to literally channel the power
of the Sun which is something that you
could expect to see Tony Stark to do in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe because
that level of intelligence and the
almost infinite resources that he has
but like you you're not gonna see that
play out yeah I mean you nobody in the
world could do that nobody in the world
could build a Dyson Sphere around the
Sun right like nobody in the world is
building like Iron Man tech you know
just it just doesn't exist right there's
nobody out there with the resources even
if they had the intelligence to do it
and so Robert Downey jr. being able to
play someone that's significantly more
intelligent than seemingly the rest of
the world then it stands to reason
Krasinski can do the same thing right
because at the end of the day the
depiction of a super intelligent
individual just comes down to
screenwriting right so long as a
screenplay is written the way it's
supposed to be Kristen Cu will look like
a genius right so it's important to kind
of keep that in mind but overall he
would nail this role now the big
question is if they do that right like
if they decide to bring Krasinski in and
hopefully Emily Blunt to play Susan
storm because I mean they're married so
why not play a married couple in the
movies then like at that point what does
it come down to well like how do you
bring them in to the MCU initially in
previous videos one of the things that I
mentioned is well you still have like
the ships of Thanos and all those things
on earth why not just use that but I
went back and I was watching Avengers in
game and one of the things I didn't
realize going through and looking at it
is it at the end of the movie when when
Iron Man snaps his fingers and does
everything everything related to Thanos
goes away where a knows his ship is gone
like all that stuff is gone in any of
the vessels that Thanos used to arrive
on earth like all that's gone right
there's there's nothing there related to
him anymore so the idea of like reverse
engineering Santos's technology and then
achieving interstellar travel is it
really there and that's actually kind of
a good thing and the reason why is
because it would just be too easy right
like it'd be something like anybody
could do right anybody with like a
master's degree in some form of
engineering could like just reverse
engineer Thanos his technology and then
suddenly there is a whole brave new
world you know it would take away the
significance of read whereas if you made
read a kind of like Zefram Cochrane's
sort of character then it becomes a lot
more significant those guys who don't
know Zeppelin Cochran is not a comic
book character he's a Star Trek
character and Zefram Cochrane from Star
Trek first
was the person who initiated first
contact right so if you ever wondered
how it was the humanity went from just
like a series of squabbling nations to
like this interstellar organization
called the Federation it's because
they're from Cochrane invented or I
guess really discovered warp travel the
ability to travel faster than light he
was the first person to achieve it on
earth and so with that being the case
that drew the attention of the Vulcans
who showed up on earth and an intern
that's how you basically get the
beginnings of the Federation and if you
do that with John Krasinski it works
exceedingly well like John Krasinski is
this guy who's just that damn smart and
he does have some input from other
people and it also be cool if you kind
of invoked the crossovers that have kind
of been started by virtue of what's
happened over the course of the MCU
right so you basically have like at the
end of Black Panther T'Challa basically
said we want to have a bigger hand in
the world out there and so you
essentially have kind of like this big
aftermath right there like up until the
events of infinity war and really even
just Avengers the Battle of New York the
humanity didn't realize that they were
not alone in the universe right like
humanity assumed that maybe there was
life out there but there was no real way
to know unless they come relatively
close to our earth and we can somehow
detect a vessel flying five they can
unanimously be seen by everybody with no
one being able to question its
authenticity right but then from there
you go into the events of New York by
the invasion of New York and Avengers
and then as holy crap there's life out
there and then humanity is kind of like
okay it's time to fast track this stuff
and figure out what we can do you know
in terms of being prepared for then
infinity war and Avengers in game
happens and it's like the worst case
scenario the humanity was caught with
his pants down it was woefully
unprepared for this invasion force you
know really Thanos and his and his
minions and whatnot and certainly could
withstand the power of the Infinity
Gauntlet so half the life in the
universe and on earth gets destroyed
over the course of you know at the end
of infinity war and then like fan o's
and his guys pop up on earth at the end
of Avengers in game and then like things
kind of unfold from there but but
literally Humanity is kind of like okay
they hit the panic button and it's like
it's time to time to figure out like how
to get past this and so I wouldn't say
that you would you would see something
like a One Nation world you know like
you have with the Federation at Star
Trek but what I would say is like
T'Challa and company coming out of
Wakanda and saying here you go humanity
here's our technology if you abuse it
we'll just shut it all down so you can't
use it anymore right so like you know
that like maybe they'll hand it over to
sort because that'd be a really cool way
to bring things in right like in the
aftermath of Avengers and Avengers
infinity war and Avengers in
that basically humanity creates the
sentient world observation and response
department which is essentially the
equivalent to shield except it monitors
space now in the MCU they'll probably
call it the Alpha Flight Program that's
what they call it in Marvel Comics but
basically you would just have this
situation where it's like okay like we
have an organization whose sole purpose
is to monitor space that's it and like
explore space and so they basically end
up bringing Reed in because he's super
smart Reed says you got to bring in
Susan because she's my wife Susan says
you got to bring in Ben Grimm because
you know he's our best friend and you
gotta bring in my brother because you
know he's my brother yeah I can't leave
him behind but that whatever manner and
whatever means you end up getting Reed
Susan Ben and Johnny and so a result of
that is using both you know technology
developed by Reed Richards combined with
existing technology linked to read from
like black panther they in turn find a
way to go into space and that could kind
of form a camaraderie between the two
right because a model Comics Reed and
Black Panther are exceedingly good
friends you know like Panther in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe doesn't seem
to be as smart at his comic book version
that role seems to be assigned to Sheree
because of the Marla comics as
intelligent as Sheree as Black Panthers
just waved where he's just that much
smarter than she is right he just he's
just that intelligent right like Black
Panther is arguably depending on how you
look at it on par with Tony Stark in
terms of how knowledgeable he is right
in the movies he's just like a guy who's
wrestling with what it means to be a
king and that's basically it right like
you don't see Black Panther doing all
the stuff to sure he's doing right he
can give it all that stuff on his own
and the comic books but he just isn't
really able to do it the movies but this
does allow kind of camaraderie to form
between the two because now they have
common ground right the technology of
Wakanda was lint to read and then using
his intelligence was expanded on and
then in turn allowed them to explore
space and then they go out into space
they're hit by some cosmic rays they
crash back down on earth and then what
do you know you got the Fantastic Four
done and done
like that's really all you need right
but but again I'm kind of curious how
you guys feel about all this right let
me know what you guys think it's super
interesting but uh but it even guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end if you are new here two comments
explain it make sure you guys did the
sub button to become part of the rob4 if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]